I think it's Warren Buffett or Charlie
Munger that says we would be able to be
happy if we just wanted to do better but
we don't we want to do better than our
next door neighbor and it's this
perpetual one-upmanship and sort of
keeping up with the Joneses people are
going to find ways to do status you know
will store who wrote that great book for
status game there's this tribe somewhere
that grows yams these unbelievably huge
yums it takes four men to wheelbarrow
these yams in and I'm pretty sure that
what you do is you give the yam to your
greatest enemy or something like that
and it's almost like this yam-shaped
middle finger you're like I'm so rich I
could forsake this yeah yeah precisely
in that case I would recommend that we
seek our status more and more in being
above that game you can see pieces of
this in just how very rich successful
people already start to behave like at a
certain level of success like it's
important that you're wearing a suit and
you drive a nice car and you have a nice
watch and you have all those signs of
status but at a certain point you show
up in a hoodie because you know they
know you're a billionaires yeah the
richest people drive the cars right
people will find ways to compete the
status status is a game that everybody
is going to continue to play